hello there my name is Karen morning
with film courage to radio show and we
are really outside the studio here where
the lobby of Elliot offer you and we
have us tomorrow a bush with us and he
is filemaker pro zen more and you can
find out more about the movie at San
has the internet filmmaking excuse me
internet marketing for filmmakers calm
and you teach your son are many things
the filmmaker to point out is it
filmmaker two point O is a new model to
come up with for pumping filmmakers to
identify Mitch audiences and start
building their audience before and
during the making of the film the idea
is that so many of my clients come to me
and so many filmmakers end up in this
situation where they make a movie and
they haven't thought about any of the
marketing ahead of time so the movies
finished maybe they go to some festivals
but they don't get a big buyer or maybe
they don't get any buyer of any kind and
then they're in this now about position
and and it's not that you can't learn
what I teach you learn internet
marketing techniques at that point in
the game but if you're starting from
zero at that point it's very difficult
so this whole magnitude when we know
models what I'm trying to do is motivate
filmmakers to start thinking about these
things at the very beginning so that in
an ideal world by the time you finish
making your film you've already got
fifty thousand a hundred thousand five
hundred thousand people on your email
list who are already predisposed to
being interested in your film which
gives you first of all because you
leverage with distributors because if
you're sitting and talking to a
distributor they're going to take much
more seriously if you say you know one
thing here's my movie please buy it it's
another thing saying here's my movie and
by the way here's the audience for my
movie and suddenly know that you know
the distributor well that's a lot less
work I have to do if the audience is
already there especially an email form
because by being able to
mass emails to that audience that
doesn't cost any money so suddenly their
savings advertising costs you're also at
that point of the process if you've got
that kind of list you're in a position
where if you don't get the distribution
deal that you want if they don't offer
you what you think is the right value
for a movie you're in position you can
perfectly comfortably walk away you can
say that's okay although itself
distributed I'll just press a button
even those 500,000 people will get an
email and also my DVD directly and you
know that's a very very powerful way to
approach being a filmmaker I think so
many a lot of what i teach goes back to
training filmmakers to move from the
sort of starving artist mentality of i
am you know I thought I'm the low
self-esteem guy that you know I need
your help because you're the big
corporate middle man who's going to sell
my stuff for me which you know again if
you find the right corporate middle man
who's willing to offer you the regular
money that can be a fantastic thing but
that only happens to a quarter percent
of all the films that you have made
which leaves thousands and thousands and
thousands pills that might count some
kind of a good audience that they can
tap into that they need to be able to
take control for themselves they need to
own their own database and I personally
I think owning your own database is
something that nobody but me really
talks about it but imagine I mean this
is one of those weird things who owns
Woody Allen's database Woody Allen
doesn't actually the studio's know
amazon owns Woody Allen's database now
woody allen is at a point in his career
he doesn't need to own his own database
because he can get paid billion dollars
of fun to make a move
you know you know the same makes a
temple and on one movie he makes takes
it off the top page himself and that
he's fine what we can do bye I mean
through the miracle of the internet we
hope is an opportunity that really
hasn't existed in history before where
we can have a direct relationship
between the artists of the audience and
build a fan base build a fan base from
the ground up but also own the
communication the means of communication
with that fan base so that if we've
collected no it doesn't have to be a
million fans we collected five thousand
fans and Facebook isn't good enough
because facebook is too general and
Facebook there are too many distractions
email opt-in emails for be the way to go
and you're still going to do Facebook
and Twitter all those things but if you
control that database then you can build
a lifelong relationship with those
people that transcends just one movie
you can take you know for example if you
especially if you have a movie or a fan
base that has a particular psychographic
as a particular niche interests if you
you know i'm working on a vampire movie
right now so let's say that by the time
I'm done with it I've got a million
people that are interested in my vampire
movie guess what I don't just I'm not
limited to just selling them the vampire
I sell me the vampire movie but I
converter halves make an affiliate deal
and selling other people's vampire
related products now I could make more
money that way I have a client who has a
wonderful sort of edgy murder mystery
called American finish that is takes
place in the sort of
sexual fetish Roland he's actually been
thinking about not doing a porn site but
because of the rabid nature of his
audience that's interested in the fetish
world and he's got a really beautiful
beautiful imagery in the film that
people respond to through talking with
me he's gotten inspired that he's going
to be doing some kind of a monthly
membership site where there will be
finished videos kinky videos again not
porn on hardcore but it's more sort of
for hard arty arty erotica but for that
particular market by building that kind
of an audience base of having access to
that kind of an audience base here's an
opportunity to make probably 10 or 20
times more money through that monthly
membership site that he ever made
through his movie and and it's not that
everybody wants to go into business that
way but the what I'm trying to get
people to do is to think in a bigger way
is to move from starving artist to
artist entrepreneurial so that you're
creating not just the marketing ability
of the ability of markets it'll fill but
you're creating a career you're creating
long-term financial
that isn't dependent on the corporate
web it isn't dependent on you know
you're sitting on your couch waiting
waiting waiting for some of you say yes
you so anyway that's Omega 2 point 0 in
a nutshell I'm babbling a little bit but
I'm very excited about it as you can
tell
you